Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo episodio di Resident Evil 4
e vi auguro una buonissima visione Let's
go Ma dai ma non ci voglio credere che è
morto così minchia sopravvissuto alle
mie granate che gli ho lanciato sotto i
piedi ed è morto così sei stato valoroso
Don Chisciotte ecco
e anche lui è scappato Mi spiace ve lo
giuro ragazzi Madonna non la passerai
liscia krauser krauser si chiama quello
là Vabbè tutto questo col coltello è
stato terribile odio il coltello ragazzi
non lo so usare c'è veramente in sto
gioco è forte Secondo me saper usare il
coltello il suo gioco fa la differenza
eh però non son buono Io con le armi da
taglio me la cavo di tipo con gli shots
la gnocca
diga
Ah ah
ah
quindi non sei proprio senza cuore
Immagino di doverti ringraziare
Christian
che dialoghi comunque incredibili cioè
tutto ironico qua che cazzo è
hai la metro sto male Mi ero dimenticato
che ci fosse la metro in sto gioco ce la
metro ognuno può andare dove cazzo gli
pare è possibile
Cos'è questo Ah piccola chiave Nice
apriamo i cassettini questo si apre Mi
sa di sì questa è la stanza principale
ora torna tutto era proprio collegato
all'alveare sta merda ecco perché era
pieno di insetti Ma la devo usare la
metro per andare avanti O semplicemente
per tornare indietro perché
effettivamente non so se
Ma che roba sto male
resistere facciamo tutta la cinematica e
ti porta fin lì 'sta cosa incredibile Ah
no qua ok Devo usarla va bene va bene va
bene Mi servono gli spinelli
lo spinner
pescetas Camon mi sembra un sacco di
soldi raga devo potenziare le armi al
massimo Eh attenzione
Che cazzo è
la statua gigantesca la statua di Ramon
No Questa era molto
ti sei fatto la statua incredibile
cacciate questa intruso
merda dov'è che sono
minchia è pieno di gente va bene chi
cazzo sono
legge Minchia gli ho sparato in testa
non ha fatto una piega Oh vattene a
[__]
Ok perfetto
ma per ora tutto ok attenzione
buono ahia
[Musica]
il prossimo comunque io la mira
dall'inizio del gioco ragazzi non siamo
migliorati manco per sbaglio Eh però
quella è un altro discorso è morto
mi chiamo Emanuele me ne sono accorto in
tempo Mori
perfetto
600 Meno male che mi danno sempre più
soldi ma me lo vado avanti perché ne ho
veramente bisogno
Che cazzo è Oh
pure
C'è un coso che da poco Porca [__] si
girava pure non ho capito E che devo
fare Ah devo fare Madonna è un casino
Beh io il tempismo ragazzi non siamo mai
andati d'accordo Non so se sei d'accordo
ma poi c'è neve trovo una merda Rossa va
ci sono a rischio tale
arrivederci Ma allora Oh che cazzo è che
mi ha lanciato Ah c'è un tizio che
lancia robe ed è utile Grazie almeno
detto adesso non ho capito se mi
conviene partire adesso Siccome devo
partire adesso vai
Ho schivato staffare Non so come ma
vabbè Togliti
non ci credo Manfredonia
dove la gente
muori quello che continua a lanciarmi le
asce Ma che te ne fai Aspetta morto è
morto
E vabbè raga' ma quanti cazzo siete Mi
ha anche scassato il giubbotto Sto
stronzo c'è tutto tutto sbagliato Ecco
il giubbotto lo devo riparare Non so
perché non mi è venuto in mente
Che cazzo è No non mi fare uscire gente
pesante perché
io mi toglierei dal cazzo
sta cadendo la palla per le scale
non sta accadendo non la vedo
Che cazzo devo caricare non ci credo
Meno male che mi ha fatto schivare Oddio
devo stare attento a schivare ste robe
Perché non è per niente semplice
però teoricamente se la gente continua
pure
uno spinello Che culo
hai rotto ugolas
vattene a [__] va' a far fuori altra
gente Vai usalo
Madonna
che figo sto male lo fa Tipo un miliardo
e anche un'altra volta le mie idee hanno
funzionato non funziona mai in realtà è
culo però va bene
Ok let's go ragazzi Let's go tiro questo
ok
Guardate sta arrivando un altro Team Ma
quanti cazzo siete in Toscana
e mi sa che tra un po' arriva gente
comunque eh Al di là del visto che è
sceso Ah c'è proprio gente lì Oh merda
il giubbotto ha messo male immagino
ok
solo questi
Mi sa di no
ma si è fatto un cazzo come fuori ok
adesso si è fatto Attenzione attenzione
attenzione attenzione questa Madonna è
pieno di gente raga Che bordello
Eh mi sa che dovevo farli fuori adesso
questi c'è il barile dicevo
No no c'è uno che li trasforma
è un po' ricaricare un'arma Porca
[__] non è un cannone Minchia puoi
saltare su una piattaforma Ti prego
prima che finisca male
è la Cavezza come dici tu Madonna Eccolo
lì lo stronzo muori muori muori è morto
E comunque tutti gli oggetti che ci sono
in giro e rimangono in giro ma perché mi
dispiace li posso sfruttare Ah chi cazzo
sei Da dove arrivi non c'è nessuno
l'ascensore era vuoto
No vabbè raga quanti cazzo siete Quanti
cazzo siete Ok uno è caduto
Che cazzo è è il Mercante quello
morti morto solo uno va bene
ok
Porca [__] dove cazzo è arrivato lo
sapete solo voi Oh
ora quello che si arrampica non ci credo
ok
Ok Forza forza forza morte son morti ci
siamo
Dopo un'ora di salita
vamos Porca [__] C'era un coso viola
prima che ho visto che era il Mercante
ma non ho fatto in tempo a prenderlo
perché mi stavo buttando risotto per
sbaglio bene Che ore sono
alle 3:00 di notte sono in tutto sto
casino va bene alla fine si sono fatte
le tre comunque un po' tardi cos'è che
fai qua
devo aprire la porta
faccio uno stronzo cecchino lo cecchino
merda
devo arrivare là dentro ragazzi che
bello perché ci sono le spine in quella
porta cazzo non lo fermare i giganti
entriamo questi qua li faccio fuori io
Anzi facciamo così
Ciao
ok Non ho ben capito mi sembrava aver
visto il Mercante a una certa perché
c'era una fiamma viola che poi non
c'entravano niente
Ah
sono morto Cioè non doveva andare che
devo stare attento mentre cammino Ok
certo che passeggiare su pezzi di legno
volanti non è il massimo
come cazzo sono come sono passati loro
in tutto sto casino eh Vedi che c'era il
Mercante non sono pazzo l'avevo visto io
incredibile cioè uno che
Salve No ho visto lei
sono qua eh
che vuoi fa lo vuoi tirare la testata in
mezzo ai [__] bello guarda
questo non so come cazzo facessero
ovunque io veramente no cioè guarda la
Red 9 se la vendo quanto mi dà
210.000 Allora teoricamente ce la potrei
fare allora capacità aumentata velocità
di ricarica ne manca due allora facciamo
così vendo questo E sti cazzi Dai fa
niente se non hai così incastrato in
mezzo fa niente dai venduto vediamo uno
due merda
95.000 e la potenza al massimo cioè
Allora è già al massimo però con la
modifica specialmente la potenza ci
accontentiamo raga Ci accontentiamo è
forti adesso la Red 9 maxata
praticamente quasi completamente maxata
adesso voglio provare veramente sta
cazzo di arma e vedere che succede
ragazza come promesso a lui
di Non dimenticare la fedeltà del suo
servo Ramon
[Musica]
che cazzo raga ogni volta arriva da
qualche parte
[Musica]
bravo
cazzo ma ci voleva tanto Oh minchia la
cosa più satisfying che è successa da
quando ho iniziato sto gioco Anche se
dubito che sia morto vediamo
non lo vedo morto
Porca [__] che schifo
Beh ramone è bello incazzato ragazzi
proviamoci sconfiggi Oddio Ma fai schifo
fai vomitare Magnum voglio provare a
usare la magnum ragazzi adesso non gli
ho sparato perché non so se
effettivamente dovete pulirlo prima
forse mi conviene indebolirlo non lo so
eh con la magnum Secondo me lo shot Ahia
[__] di tua madre morta Ma che è
successo Secondo me riesco a shottarlo
con la magnum vediamo
Porca [__]
l'ho colpito
ho fatto male uh che male eh non ci
arrivo lì devo fare così aspetta
dai ho fatto molto Io ho fatto molto più
male così che con come doveva fare lui
avevo capito Chris ho capito una
bestemmia raga Meno male non era quello
Ahia che male
Che male Mi serve Mi serve Porca [__]
che cazzo è che cazzo è che cazzo ahia
ahia
Madonna ragazzi però incredibile Secondo
me ecco esatto che almeno lo becco
ragazzi è fortissima lavagna ma è troppo
forte Sono fortissimo lo shottato
la magnum sciotta la magnum sciotta è
troppo forte un giorno come sono
contento rossetto in tre che questo qua
ha droppato un rossetto mi ha droppato
io ho ammazzato un tipo che mi ha
droppato un rossetto in Resident Evil Ok
però che valga un po' non so cosa se ne
fa il Mercante però glielo vendo Madonna
che botte mi ha dato comunque ha fatto
malissimo però gli ho fatto più male io
mi chiama Magnum raga' la magno Guarda
sono un genio tutto da parte per la
magnum Ho anche preso tutta quella roba
che Teoricamente vale un botto di soldi
quindi se arrivo di nuovo Dal mercante
Dovrei riuscire teoricamente poi non lo
so Dovrei riuscire a scambiarla ehm cioè
a venderla per per potermi potenziare al
massimo this One dove cazzo stiamo
andando raga
qua siamo usciti proprio al castello
cioè stiamo andando da un'altra parte uh
browser Sparagli dove la stai portando
Porca [__] potevo prenderlo per una
volta l'ho fatto io cioè potevo fare non
è una cinematica li potevo fare sul
serio però niente Non potevo colpirlo
Peccato Sarebbe fighissimo se i
videogiochi fossero così immaginate
senza linearità cioè tu spari a uno e
boh finisce il gioco tipo all'inizio
sarebbe strano Vabbè ma sto svarionando
raga è inutile che continuo a parlare di
ste robe e mi serve un mercante che
tanto è ogni 5 metri ne trovi uno
cantino
Quindi se me ne vado teoricamente non
posso più tornare indietro Quindi tutte
le cose che dovevo fare qua posso
saltate
Ah bella Sì tipo il motore della barca
hanno le chiavi ok
questo non ci fosse il motore comunque
questa qua non l'ho ancora inquadrata in
tutto ciò Cioè sta durando veramente
tantissimo di più rispetto agli altri
remake di residentivolo ce l'avevo già
finiti due volte gli altri miei questo
dura tantissimo Meno male a guida' io lo
Guida alla barca oh ero bravo guidato
nell'ago l'altra volta
sembra che tu abbia qualcosa da dirmi lì
che sei gnocca
a dubito rispondere chiaramente
Sai dopo l'incidente
il mondo è cambiato
cerchi di salvare una persona e ne
muoiono certo
sono cambiato anch'io
non sei cambiato
pensi di averlo fatto
che
Ecco la mia domanda
tu sei cambiata
o stai di nuovo cercando di usarmi
secondo te
ci siamo
Bellissima la voglio anch'io
ci vediamo
Finisce sempre così
[Musica]
ecco sta parte proprio non me la ricordo
quindi non so bene
capitolo 13 siamo in dirittura d'arrivo
Secondo me ragazzi Secondo me sono 15
capitoli totale Non lo so Eh lo vedo
bello incazzato sto posto Se devo essere
sincero Però vabbè volendo li posso
cecchinare già tutti eh non è che anche
i laser
Ma che cazzo qua c'è un bordello raga
Eccola Ashley
Madonna che casino Ok Allora vediamo di
riuscire a fare le cose fatte bene
quindi non stava nel castello ma non mi
ricordavo sta cosa
E che succede Vabbè non ci vado io la
faccio prima secondo te devo disattivare
prima sti cosi sta merdaccia di coso
no distruggi
arrivi proprio spegnerlo va bene cioè
dovrò scoprire se ci passano i nemici in
mezzo succede qualcosa perché
effettivamente potrei sfruttarli per far
sparare agli altri però non ho capito se
sparano ste cose non ho capito Vabbè
'sti cazzi Eh però li scopriremo giorno
questo non mi ha visto però eh
Mi sa che invece mi ha visto merda
raga' Però la Madonna di Dio questo con
questo uso la magnum faccio prima
secondo me qua posso già utilizzare dei
colpi della Magnum Eh no non proprio sui
gli stronzi qualunque
E qua mi sa che devo sfruttare le cose
che c'ho adesso caputtana Vabbè che
l'arma questa qua è fortissima Quindi
teoricamente posso usare anche questo
Arca [__]
non dimentichiamoci che la pistola ce
l'ho mazzata Quindi tanto vale usarla
Ok ok comunque durano gli ho sparato col
fucile a pompa è ancora durano sti qua
merda
allo zio quello grande figlio di [__]
lo zio Quello che spara là dietro
Minchia mi ha fatto malissimo Porca
vacca non ho cure non ho Cure sto male
Vabbè Eh lo so che non ho più mi sono
accorto anch'io
Ok tira un calcione davanti ai [__]
ritiro un calcione
E vabbè Ragazzi sto coso è troppo forte
Oh
mi conviene cecchinarlo a sto punto
Vediamo se funziona
muori
è morto è morto ce l'ho fatta quattro
colpi dal cecchino lo butto giù eh
quindi Ricordiamocelo
non è male attenzione
ma questo ancora vivo
porca [__] porca
[Musica]
merda
scavalca quanto tempo Madonna
OK OK OK OK OK OK OK OK OK OK Ecco me ne
arrivano altri Oh vieni Che posso va Sta
vita qua Eh vediamo di salire qua non
c'è gente Ah vedi che però posso fa
' agli [__] Ma chi è io non vedo
la gente ti ho visto te invece eh
ci siamo spinti a vicenda io a lui lui a
me va bene
Ma chi cazzo Mi sta sparando chi Ah tu
sei A stronzo
muori morto è caduto perfetto
è andata praticamente andata
Oh yeah baby vedi che funziona lo sapevo
funzionava ho fatto un giro incredibile
ma ci sono Vabbè mezzo pistola si vola
Camon ha fatto fuori 62 mila persone ma
tutto ok ragazzi tutto ok Normale
amministrazione
andiamo avanti Salve
che mira del cazzo che c'ho
Ok ok
lo voglio ragazzi il prossimo residenti
non lo voglio ambientato in Italia
Voglio vedere che succede ma per
curiosità eh
Ok ok
Ah Dal mercante devo ripararmi
l'armature sono stupido non l'ho fatto
sono proprio stupido È la prima cosa che
devo fare Ragazzi mi devo ricordare
assolutamente di riparare l'armatura
Orca merda
[Musica]
è morto
questo che cazzo è magari sei uscito
dalla seconda guerra mondiale Sì Ahò
è morto
ora è morto ok
si prosegue raga giorno
piano piano piano piano piano piano
piano piano piano piano
come ha fatto non vedeva sei orbo sei
ordorbo lo sapevo che avrei potuto
ancora farlo fuori perché si vedeva che
non era proprio sveglio il servizio bene
di qua
sto a chi
e mi sa che questo mi ha visto questo
purtroppo non sono riuscito a farlo
fuori Style
Però vabbè sti cazzi c'è ancora gente
Secondo me qua ci sarà un'altra di
quelle Fight come la chat di chi è dov'è
merda
vabbè a sto punto me ne vado è stato è
stato interessante comunque ma cioè ma
mi sta inseguendo
mi faccio il cazzacci miei la prossima
volta vai Sparagli Ah gli posso anche
sparare alla sto coso in alto
effettivamente
ha funzionato
sono fortissimo sono fortissimo grazie
C'è ancora qualcuno c'è ancora quello
col lanciarazzi tutto ciò quindi siamo
tranquilli Porca [__]
Oddio che cazzo è
c'è una via segreta qui aiuto Oddio
cos'è apri apri apri apri veloce veloce
veloce veloce veloce
questi hanno lo scudo di ferro io sto
male
se gli spunta il coso sono nella merda
e [__] Che cazzo ti devo sparare
la magnum
Tra l'altro mi sa che mi devo curare
perché sono praticamente morto non è che
ho trovato un'altra roba gialla ok
E vabbè ragazzi siete invincibili Allora
fate il cazzo che vi pare
hai finito tu con lo scudo di merda ok
Questo è morto funziona quello dietro
facciamo dietro
perfetto perfetto
bene bene bene a posto sono morti tutti
Manca solo quello col lanciarazzi mi sa
Eh che ancora vivo sicuro Chi è che hai
detto La merda
se puede
morto
morto o merda che preferisco comunque
sparargli con questa qua perché cioè è
troppo forte il cecchino vorrei
sfruttarlo per le boss Fight insieme
alla Magnum ragazzi
morto Yes non è morto un cazzo è morto
anche meno raga anche meno Eccolo qua
2 e 3 e vattene a [__] va
very nice lanciarazzi lo posso prendere
attenzione venite venite venite
a prendere No mi ha dato munizioni
pistola sarebbe stato fighissimo
utilizzare lanciarazzi ma mi sa che lo
posso solo comprare non l'ho mai
comprato raga perché Lo vendeva al
mercato lo vende ancora però non
mi sembra di togliermi già con la magnum
Comunque mi facilito le cose però vabbè
Questa è mio merito perché mi sto
tenendo proiettili perché potrei
sfruttarli anche per i medio boss tipo
quelli con la motosega eccetera però
teoricamente usare proprio il
lanciarazzi mi sembra vabbè che te lo
devi comprare costa un sacco di soldi ma
non mi va di skippare proprio le boss
Fight come skippare una bossfight Cioè
tu compri lo Skip di una boss Fight
Secondo me no se sono le no mi chiamate
non ce l'ha
bella Mira
morto maestro
[Musica]
brutto mostro di merda
se mi arriva qualcuno Da dietro sono
morto Raga non vedo nessuno
[Musica]
secondo me c'è qualcuno mi sta arrivando
da dietro ma io che vado avanti
a posto Vediamo se c'era No ho fatto una
strage Random va bene sono contento
Ok ragazzi C'è roba qua
d'altro Ho anche già un sacco di soldi
adesso Sai che è questo
c'è una bomba Che cazzo è
Ah era una bomba Apri la porta esplodeva
la porta Grazie Poi gentilissimi Cioè
Meno male che me ne sono accorto
eh fratello non
vieni qua l'ho fatto per attirarlo e poi
non so se è stupido
ragazzi veramente Fatevi vedere da uno
bravo Ma bravo forte e non parlo di
WhatsApp Eccolo il controllo perfetto
armadietti cos'è fucile devo aumentarmi
anche la capienza della della valigetta
Attenzione ragazzi Ricordiamoci porta
aperta
si vola e permesso ho aperto io eh
Quindi tranquilli so io
sento Un ruggito
Minchia veramente ci passi ci passi 60
volte ci passi se ti metti di lato ma
guardalo e anche questo episodio di
Resident Evil è finito ma ci vediamo al
prossimo episodio Visto che stiamo
facendo a manetta e spero che vi stia
piacendo questa cosa mi sta facendo un
culo quadro per fare tutti quanti uno
scherzo no no sto scherzando Veramente
quello quadro ma mi piace un sacco
quindi lo si fa con piacere iscrivetevi
al canale lasciate un bel commento mi
piace e noi ci vediamo come sempre al
prossimo video bella ragazzi